- Buzzfeed.
(laughs)
On the count of three
you always listen to what your mother says
and never question it.
- No (bleep) that, I'm not doing that.
(crew laugh)
(jovial music)
I'm so excited about this video right now.
I'm so excited, excited, excited, excited.
Oh.
Today I'm gonna be learning
everything about hypnosis
and I'm not just gonna be learning it,
I'm gonna do it.
Basically I'm gonna be a God,
I'm gonna control people.
I'm gonna have so much power.
All these people who never listen to me,
who never care what I
have to say, guess what.
Today you're gonna do whatever I say.
So this is easy, hypnosis
is basically just
people being controlled by
their subconscious mind.
I don't know if you guys
get it, but I get it,
so I'm gonna go test it
out on some people. Swish.
Can I try and hypnotize you?
- Um, I guess.
- Alright, we're gonna do this, ready?
Just give me your hands.
(ambient music)
Open sesame.
And every step you go
down, you get closer.
And every- (laughs)
(laughs)
(clinking)
When I snap my finger,
you will open your eyes
and you will tap dance
your way around the office.
(snap)
- Nah, man. (both laugh)
- Look right there, sleep.
I did it.
Wake up. (snap)
(suspenseful music)
It doesn't say anything, there's no like-
- I'm just kidding with you dude.
- Oh (bleep).
(laughs)
That was the most terrifying thing ever.
I'm not doing it again,
it's done, it's over.
I'm gonna bring in an expert.
Right when the expert was
about to enter the room
I actually got really nervous.
I didn't know what I was getting into
but I was ready to learn.
How's it going?
- Good, how are ya?
- Good, good to meet you.
You are the hypnotist.
- I am.
- You hypnotize people.
- I do.
- Before I actually have
you be a part of this video,
I need to make sure you're legit.
So would you be able to
perform hypnosis on me
to prove that you can do it.
- Absolutely, do you
want to be hypnotized?
- I do, I really want to get hypnotized.
- It's about you allowing yourself
to relax your conscious mind.
We're able to go through critical factor
and put suggestions in there
to help you with stress.
- I actually had chronic
headaches for two years.
I went to doctors, I took
all kinds of medication,
nothing helped, and then
I went to a therapist
who does hypnosis and all
she did was just talk to me
as I was relaxed.
My headaches were cured
and I'm not scared of flying anymore.
- I generally have people
stop smoking in one session.
That's it you're done.
- [Eric] He told me to
close my eyes and just relax
and listen to his voice and then
he started doing some crazy stuff.
- So just take a nice deep breath.
(snap)
Deeper, relax.
Just letting go, five,
deeper, four, deeper, relax,
three, really feeling
good, two, fully relaxed,
and when I count from one to three
it will be as if you're a male stripper.
One, two, three.
(sensual pop music)
How we doing, Eric?
How do you feel?
- I'm good.
You wanna see some stuff?
I don't know how they
do it in Magic Mike but.
What?
Guys, this is my first
time watching this footage.
I'm mindblown, I'm uncomfortable.
So I just wanna tell you
exactly what was going through my mind
because it looks so crazy.
So when he was talking to
me I just felt super relaxed
and like I was meditating and
just listening to his voice
but as soon as he said
'You're gonna be like a
male stripper,' whatever,
in my head I thought,
'You know, (bleep) you,
I'm not gonna do that,'
and then he snapped his fingers,
I opened up and I stopped caring
and my body just started moving.
I didn't know what I was
doing, I was just okay with it.
It felt really good, that's
what's weird about it.
I felt really relaxed and like free,
but I just wanna clarify
a lot of people think that
hypnosis is like 'Oh, you're this puppet'
'and you're unconscious and
someone has control over you.'
It's not.
You know what's going on the
whole time and it's crazy.
Sorry, I just had to get that out there.
Let's get back to the video.
A lot of my friends
said hypnosis was fake.
So we're gonna go around
the office right now
and just hypnotize a bunch of my friends.
(light music)
- How you feeling today?
- Honestly I'm a little stressed.
- How would you like to be
more calm and be more relaxed?
- I've been trying to like
meditate and relax at work
all my three years here
so if you can actually
give me something that
works, I would be shocked.
- There is something about
this man in his eyes.
There is something inside that
is already very hypnotizing.
- [Eric] The hypnotist
spent the next 10 minutes
trying to relax each person
and once they were ready
he put them in a trance.
- Sleep.
- [Eric] It looked like he was
knocking these people out unconscious
but they were just super relaxed.
Sarah was so relaxed that
she just fell to the floor.
- Let go on me.
Don't let me down, I got you.
Relax. Deeper to go, feel, 10, deeper-
- [Eric] It didn't work
on everyone though.
- One, two, sleep.
Just go ahead and just relax.
- [Eric] You have to be
open to getting hypnotized
and just let things go.
Dave let things go just a little too much.
His eyes went white.
And if a person's eyes are fluttering
that means they're in a hypnotic state.
He told each person to
imagine their happy place
and to rub their fingers together.
By doing so they're
creating an anchor point,
and so every single
time they do this motion
they'll be able to go
back to their happy place.
It was really cool to see
what a positive effect
the hypnosis had on each person.
(Brenda laughs)
- Oh my God.
- I feel like I just came
out of an hour long massage.
- I know.
- Except I was able to
actually like relax.
- I'm excited to try this at night
because I have like a lot of
trouble sleeping, bad anxiety.
- It was not scary, it
was just very relaxing.
It was like finally being able to reach
this meditative state.
- You know, we don't take enough time
for ourselves these days to
really think and connect.
- [Eric] I'm glad people loved it so much
and you guys get to see that
there's more to hypnosis
than just acting like a fool.
But obviously I still made him
put them back into a trance
so we can mess with them.
He made Sarah forget the number six.
- Go ahead and count on
your fingers from one to 10.
- One, two, three, four,
five, seven, eight, nine, 10.
One, two, three, four, five.
four, five.
- [Eric] He convinced her
every math problem equaled 382.
- How much is one plus one?
- 382.
- How much is five plus zero?
- He made Brenda forget her name.
- My name's Brian, what's your name?
- Diana.
- Diana, cool. Is that her name?
(Brenda laughs)
Diana.
What's your name?
I'm sorry, what was your name again?
- I can't think of it. (laughs)
I feel this weird buzz.
Why can't I think, oh my God.
- My name's Brian, what was your name?
(gasps)
Isn't that weird? (laughs)
- [Eric] He also made her forget English
and told her she can only speak martian.
- What is your favorite kind of food?
(speaks gibberish)
- And what's the culture like there?
- I've been watching this guy all day
and I think I know what I need to do.
It's all about just making
the person feel comfortable,
turning on their
imagination by having them
think about a place they'd like to be,
and then once they're fully relaxed,
their eyes are fluttering,
their head is hanging loose,
you give them a suggestion
and snap your fingers
or count to three.
So I thought why not bring somebody in
who's had control over me my entire life.
Flip things around.
I'm gonna hypnotize my mom.
So as soon as I snap my
fingers and say sleep,
I want you to try to go back
to that state of relaxation.
Drop your body, relax,
one, two, three, sleep.
(ambient music)
So once I say three,
you will open your eyes
and only be able to speak
and communicate in Russian. Three.
How's it going?
No one understands you here.
Do you speak English?
(laughs)
You're auditioning for American Idol.
You will sing your original song.
(snap)
Get into it, more into it.
They want more, they want some more.
And sleep.
I think I did it, hypnosis is very fun.
It helps people relax, rest, go to sleep,
if you can't sleep at night,
if you have too many thoughts,
and it's also fun if you can
kinda give people suggestions
and they go along with it.
Alright, so normally when I
finish these types of videos,
I freak out and I'm like
'Oh my God, I did it.'
'I mastered it, I did it.'
But the reason I wasn't
freaking out in this video
was because I couldn't
figure out if my mom
was faking it or not.
Because if she wasn't that means
that I actually hypnotized her.
It just doesn't seem possible.
You guys are not excited
so I feel like you know
she's lying. Is she lying?
- I've been trying to figure
it out this whole time.
- Mom, are you serious?
- I'm serious.
- Well, it's up to the audience to decide
if I really hypnotized my mom or not.
I don't know so I'm not faking it.
My mom might be faking this whole thing.
Just give the audience a little juice,
if you're lying admit it right now.
- I never lie.
(upbeat electronic music)